good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday
hope everyone's having an amazing day it
is so [ __ ] hot in this
town yeah i'm moving to iceland well is
it cold in iceland
well actually iceland is green and
greenland is icy
fun fact that i learned from the real
housewives of orange county yes i would
like to move to the place
that is i say greenland so [ __ ] hot
like
disgusting disgusting well it's a heat
wave
oh i've heard i watch the local news and
everyone is experiencing it
wherever they are probably yeah i'm i
don't know how your
heat wave is kind of affecting you but
for me it's like the most
insane chub rub like i've ever
experienced in my life
can't even literally just you're
building i keep thinking about this i
think i've recently noticed due to the
heat wave that
my building hallways don't have air
conditioning like the lobby does
and then again the elevator start
getting a little hot and then when i get
to the hallway it's like hot and not
until i open my door do i feel like that
cool gust of wind
my i don't know if my hallways have air
conditioning but they're not that hot
but sometimes they are but then
sometimes they're not i don't know maybe
we're all opening our doors more or
something
like i'm taking out the trash and i'm
schvitzing
yeah and that's what i'm experiencing
right now i'm so sorry
i'm sorry for you too like we're all
experiencing it yeah i mean i feel like
i'm faring better than you you know just
because
it's annoying i feel mostly for brew he
doesn't get to enjoy his time outside
he's like when he comes back he's so
unwell yeah
just like brew it's it's just a little
heat wave theo's experiencing the same
thing but this is bruce for
summer and so he doesn't know how the
seasons change so he's experiencing it
all for the first time it must be so
confusing i'm sure it is i'm trying to
explain to him
you know first comes fall winter spring
summer
then we'll go back to fall or some would
say
winter spring summer though
that is ben's favorite [ __ ] song
that's weird i know when i met him he
was like
obsessed with that song and it's like a
cute song i think
his sentiment comes from toy story i'm
just like that's a weird song for a
grown man to like be obsessed with
but i think ben's parents are obsessed
with it so it's like a family song which
is sweet
but it's just like a weird fact about
ben that is a weird fact about ben
i'm definitely gonna look at him
differently when i see him later right
it's weird
yeah yeah for sure but i i guess i can
understand people have weird things
about them
yeah i have like a makeup brush bristle
like stuck in my nostril so if it looks
like i'm picking my nose i'm not
yeah we do need to clarify when these
things happen yeah i mean
my favorite thing to do is on a long car
drive drive past people and see people
who are picking their nose like
it is my true favorite pastime and i was
doing it the other day me and ben were
driving back from
long island and i saw the craziest thing
it was a big pickup truck we're pulled
up next to him
the guy who's driving is holding a beer
it's just like crazy he was holding a
corona and his wife or girlfriend in the
front seat was too and they were just
like chugging coronas whilst
driving and i knew that like people
drove drunk but i don't think people
actually like
drove whilst drinking no they they don't
that's illegal
yeah i know and i was like i felt very
helpless i wanted to do something but
like what was there to do
yeah were you guys on the highway yes i
think it was very slow rolling um there
was a lot of traffic on the
slide it got bored on the highway no
literally i wouldn't
be here i would have been like much more
worried if we were like driving 60
but it's not good either way no no it's
really awful either way that's a
horrible
example it's crazy things you see when
you just aren't on your phone on the
highway
i'm never on my phone on the highway the
fun fact about me anytime i get in the
car
i have to be off my phone so i barely
see everything because you get nauseous
right yeah i can't look at my phone i
would literally vomit so
any time i'm in the car and also i can't
speak in the car really
so i mean like the other day i was
driving with my friends and we were all
talking the whole time and it was fine
but like
if we're taking if we're both in the
back seat of a car like don't speak to
me
i try you try yeah yeah i know who loves
to talk in the car
the snitch chatty [ __ ] kathy in a car
been too and like sometimes it's just
like
no like we're in this for the long haul
like shut up
yeah i just want to look out the window
that's all and get lost in my thoughts
well i just want to be on my phone i
can't believe you survived like hours
long car rides without being on your
phone like
what do you do i look out the window and
i i see what's going on out there
i the thought of being left alone with
my thoughts is so
chilling i'm so not interested in my
thoughts no it's really interesting to
look out the window and like
see the world around you i feel like
people miss so much
in their own cities yeah because they're
not just paying attention looking around
heads up
yeah it's try it sometime it's
interesting yeah um speaking of
interesting we've such a great show for
you guys today
i did catch up on all four of the first
new episodes of too out to handle
and i was really just reminded what a
supreme reality show it is it's just so
good they really know exactly when to
throw a curveball
change the rules and the cast is really
really good i'm really
like a lot of the people are starting to
grow on me i like the girls a lot better
than the guys
um i think that was also the case last
year because they purposely like
cast [ __ ] boys and it's just so annoying
um but all the girls i really love like
i'm obsessed with melinda she's
literally like the star of the show and
her
i don't know how whenever we watch these
shows like bachelor in paradise or like
love island
the logistics behind it always kind of
boggle my mind because they're supposed
to be camera ready hair glam makeup
in insane heat and in insane living
quarters and i just don't know how they
do it and melinda is showing up like
every outfit more seconding than the
next every makeup glam more sickening
different hairstyles it's just it's so
impressive and it deserves
some credit i just i really um cannot
wait for the next four episodes it's
such a good show and i think you'll
really enjoy it no i know that i will i
have not had a moment to watch it but i
will get to it this week because i
finished the redheads book last night
the future of fragile things so good i
think we're gonna have such a great
episode because i know everybody really
liked it
so we're recording tonight get your
questions in the redheads book club
gmail.com especially questions comments
concerns if you didn't like the book let
us know why
we love all different opinions do you
ever get like redheads hate mail to that
account
later this [ __ ] sucks you guys are a
bunch of bookworms for us
never that's how somebody should do it
that's how beloved the podcast is
you know can't relate so i wish i had a
beloved podcast
um get your questions in we're recording
tonight i'm really excited about that
episode drops on thursday
um and it's never too late to become a
redhead so i just wanted to remind you
of that fact
yeah no you learned something new every
day it's pretty sick pretty pretty sweet
so i was busy with that yesterday and i
will get to too hot to handle have a lot
on my content plate
and i will i will get through it i have
to tell you something
okay so and i'm telling you this so you
don't go watching it and you don't fall
into the trap that i fell into
okay so there was this tick-tock trend
where everyone was like
oh my god you know 20 minutes into the
third episode of this netflix original
show
sex life and i was like it was like they
didn't tell you what it was but they
were just like
oh my god oh my god like talking about
this moment and like you know i'm a tick
talker i want to know like what the kids
are up to
jackie like it was so not what i was
expecting this
20-minute mark in the third episode of
sex life like if you know you know
life that's what the show is called okay
it's about a woman who likes her sex
life
kind of she has like this perfect life
with this like hot husband house in
connecticut she goes on to work
and the only thing missing is like she
used to be like this crazy like sex
fiend and like did you know 79 kamasutra
positions
and her husband's just like kind of lame
but he's like hot um he's just like not
a great lover
she's struggling with this like should
she go back to her toxic ex who like
gave her great dick i don't know
um yeah no by the way it is except it
has that
lifetime element where it's like a fake
tv show dramatic like i was watching
after i saw
the thing and it was like the narration
it was so cringy it was like
very danielle steele you know i wouldn't
be surprised if this was based on
one of those novels i understand what
was the thing do you want to know
yeah okay so spoiler alert
it's not that crazy so her husband like
knows that she is still like obsessed
with this guy brad who
and he like follows him to the gym and
like wants to see what it's all about
they work out they go into the gym and
he's showering
so he's showering and then like the guy
brad turns around
and like the husband's face drops
because this guy brad has like
literally a 15 inch penis like
jackie it's literally the size of my arm
it's did they show you the penis yes i
was so
gab smoked gobsmacked snacks i did not
know that's what we were gonna say
and i literally like lost my [ __ ]
mind and then i was
on dumois and everyone was talking about
it and like
she got intel that it's not a prosthetic
like this guy
he was trending on twitter yesterday
like that it's really
him so like that's kind of what i did
yesterday
after i watched you out to handle and it
was literally like a shock
you're not used to seeing penises on
your television no you're really not
okay first two things one obviously i'm
gonna go
you have to see what everyone's talking
about
two how did you know all the backstory
about this show watch
you watch the show oh yeah after i saw
the penis i had to start from the
beginning
okay so now i'm on episode four it gets
so bad so fast it's like
it's actual community theater like the
acting is so bad
and then i wanted to see what people
were saying about it online and there
are all these articles like really
trying to make something out of it like
this netflix show is taking talking
about female pleasure in a real way
like it's a real like porn
show like it's i didn't finish it so i
don't know how it ends so maybe i'm
speaking but like
it ain't that deep that's hysterical no
i know it was like these articles i'm
like
are you watching the same thing that i'm
watching because it's not
that's really funny okay add it to the
play 20 minute mark
third episode you don't even need to
watch the show okay but honestly the
show sounds good
and i i feel like i'm so animated like i
described it so well
um and i don't know if it's that good i
do like a lifetime
vibe you do actually but i have to be in
the right mindset and i've been in such
a serious mindset i actually don't know
if i can pivot
just go to three minutes three episodes
20 minutes see if you're
intrigued and then maybe start from the
beginning like i did okay cool cool cool
yeah
um so that's what i did yesterday that
is really cool thank you for sharing
you're welcome and you know
we talk about the hot topics here and
like literally everyone's talking about
this man's penis like we have to
okay no i'm really glad i feel so in the
know i watched that episode
for research thank you i was working
you're a researcher
no i'm constantly committed to the craft
of this show
thank you and if that means looking at a
14 inch schlong then that's what i'll do
someone's got to do it and i guess it
was me
okay well thank you for that i feel like
speaking of being in the know
i feel like without further ado for sure
adida do we could get into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
babel this summer get the most out of
your travels abroad by learning the
language of your destination with babel
the number one selling language learning
app from ordering in restaurants or
asking for directions to gaining a
deeper understanding of the culture
babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy
with bite-sized lessons you actually can
use in the real world
babble is a cat miss travel essential
all so much travel is opening up this
summer and if you want to i don't know
like meet the paulo to your lizzy or
i don't know order a gelato in the
native language get on babble
so you can really be like a true
traveler not a tourist like a traveler
babel offers 15-minute lessons that make
it the perfect way to learn a new
language
unlike the infamous language classes you
took in high school babel designs their
courses with practical real world
conversations in mind
it's things you'll get to use in
everyday life with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
plus babel speech recognition their
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent because you
want to be that guy you know
i love the parmigiano reggiano not
parmesan not parmesan reggie
definitely not there are many ways to
learn with babel in addition to lessons
you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes and right now when you
purchase a three month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free
so that's six months just for the price
of three go to babel.com and use the
promo code tmt
that's babble.com b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code tmt as in the morning toast tmt for
an extra three months free check it out
and
go find your paulo check it out and
babble on
that's that lady gaga song oh this ad
always reminds me of it oh that's funny
yeah
it's it has to do with you know the
nature of babbling no and i'm
constantly thinking about babylon
yeah like where it all started a hundred
percent i remember learning about
babylon in like fifth grade i'm like
damn connected yeah i feel very
connected to the story of babylon
that's beautiful i think maybe in
another life like i was there like a
dead serious
i can like see it in my head is that
that's so crazy because that's how i
feel about the tower of babel i think
about
that i tried i told you about the tower
battle when we first got this
babel ad because it relates back to the
name babel because it's about languages
and if you don't know the story of the
tower of babel you should check it out
because it's a really interesting story
for sure and it's like the
the story behind how languages were
invented yeah and i definitely
remember what you said about it because
i can't i think if i told you the story
again
yeah no i just want to let you know like
i've literally no idea what you're
talking about
remember when we first were doing a
babylon and i was like wow that's such a
great name because
we didn't have this conversation on the
show it was offline and i said because
of the tower of babel that's like where
biblically languages come from because
all of these familiar yeah these people
were building a really tall tower they
wanted to get into the heavens and the
tower was getting too high so then god
created languages
so they couldn't communicate anymore and
keep building
stunning story check it out yeah
okay that's your biblical lesson of the
day and now it is time for the first
story which is some bachelor drama
oh my god you guys bachelor stars got
ppp loans during the pandemic tasha and
colton are responding to the criticism
okay several big names from the bachelor
franchise are catching flack from
receiving money from the government's
paycheck protection program during the
pandemic the two of them so far are
defending it
if you don't know the ppp loans were
meant to aid small businesses and allow
them to keep their workforce employed
during the coveted crisis
and the new public records revealed
companies associated with bachelor stars
like tasha adams and ari landike
received loans in the past year in the
amounts of 20
eight hundred and 833.20 dollars
respectively the companies that actually
receive the ppp loans are interesting
tasha named her company tasha adams
media llc
and ahri's is called instagram husband
llc so embarrass that's like the most
embarrassing part of this whole story
like no not like taking advantage of a
system but like that's what your llc is
called
totally shame another notable one is
colton underwood
legacy foundation which received an 11
355
ppp loan and dale moss who applied for a
20 dollar loan but it doesn't look like
that one has been dispersed yet okay so
let's
let's dive into this also with that
article i've been on bachelor reddit
like reading
and then you saw surfaced on
bachelorette also brian absolo yes so i
feel like there's many different
categories here and i
i can really argue both sides because i
feel so conflicted like i really do
but the thing is is that colton
underwood has a foundation with
employees like honestly i let him off
the hook i really do
yeah he said that his rep said colton's
nonprofit filed for the ppp loan after
their annual fundraising events were
cancelled due to covid
none of the ppp went directly to colton
in fact colton has never received any
form of payment from the foundation all
the proceeds go directly to people
living with cystic fibrosis i believe
that even though i hate colton like want
to make him a monster
i believe it i do brian abasolo got
two loans one in 2020 and then another
one like two months ago
brian abasolo is a chiropractor he has
an office with receptionists and like
nurses like
those people need to get paid he has a
full-blown front-facing consumer-facing
business like
i too i believe i'll give brian abasolo
the benefit of the dog yes
tasha also um her people put out a
statement explaining her loan
and i think this is where i have a bit
of an issue because
read the statement they said her rep
said the primary purpose of the pvp loan
is to help
business owners retain their existing
employees and to create jobs for
americans who are financially impacted
by the coven 19 pandemic
as a business owner television and
podcast host and brand ambassador tasha
obtained the ppp loan that enabled her
to hire an employee to whom she offers
market-based pay
and benefits tmz is told the employee
tasha hired with the ppp money was
previously
previously laid off from a media company
at the start of the pandemic
the rep adds that since exhausting the
pvp loan funds but in light of the
growing economy tasha is committed to
retaining her ploy
for the foreseeable future so like she
got the loan
so that she could hire someone and it's
like we love to see a job being created
but is that what the ppp loan was for it
was for people whose businesses were
suffering and who couldn't pay their
employees wanting to make sure that
so there's it's just it's very morally
ambiguous and to me
the real uh and
and i consider dale to be in the same
category as tasia but at the same time
i don't know if i can really fault
anyone who took a loan out in like april
of 2020 things were
so uncertain and honestly like i can see
someone like freaking out
but a lot of these bachelor people took
out loans like as of two months ago
which is kind of
and the influencer economy has picked up
i think there's more jobs
in that space than ever and honestly a
few months into cobid like being an
influencer
who worked with brands was like the best
thing like it was non-stop work like
we've spoken to so many influencers who
said they made more money last year
than it had in their entire career so
like i don't know it does
the people who applied for loans in
march and april of 2021 like
that really bothers me that rubs me the
wrong way especially when some of them
live in like
you know states that have been open for
a really long time like if you live in
l.a or new york like i can understand
i'm feeling so conflicted because parts
parts of it bother me but then also like
just my philosophy is like
i really don't like to count other
people's money you really don't know
like what goes on and part of being an
influencer
is making the world think you're richer
than you are and
so you just don't know what goes on but
then it's like
i think of ahri and lauren who are kind
of taking the brunt of this
media scandal antaisha um and i kind of
think rightfully so like they literally
have
such a successful youtube channel they
just didn't remember we thought they
were moving to hawaii but they bought a
second home that they're
renovating in hawaii like that just
feels really icky
and weird and also ari's a real estate
agent in
like phoenix which literally is one of
the biggest like housing markets because
of cobid so many people like moved to
different suburbs and scottsdale
phoenix area was one of them so i just
feel like really icky about it as a
taxpayer you know
yeah i do pay my taxes and it's not
enjoyable i
agree with everything that you said i
think nick viall summed it up pretty
well also he said what's legal isn't
always right what's illegal isn't always
wrong don't know everyone's situation
but my gut tells me any alum applying
for a ppp is both savvy and shitty
interesting debate
i think it is an interesting debate and
i remember in the past year there have
been so many
ppp um loans that have come out that
were like public figures
celebrities extremely rich people who
have like companies tom brady
tom brady i was reading on page six like
reese witherspoon for her draper james
yeah i think lebron yeah and i remember
we had this conversation in the past and
it's like
but these people have companies who have
employees who need to get paid
and that's what the ppp loan was meant
to do right and i think some of the
resentment
rightfully comes from people who know
you know their parents or
a friend of theirs who runs a small
business and was really struggling
didn't get approved for a ppp
loan but then like lauren and rer and it
just feels gross and that's such a fair
call but like also where's the
responsibility
like who's approving these people yeah
just look them up on instagram
you know so yes it is a savvy thing to
do
kind of like taking advantage of what's
going on but also like we can hate the
player but we should also hate the game
like who is approving these applications
yeah that's very true
so i'm just feeling really torn and i
also feel like defensive a little bit
of just like the influencer industry in
general because i think like when an
influencer does something people just
love to like hate influencers
so they like you know make it into such
a bigger deal i feel like there's more
news about this
than reece witherspoon and reese
witherspoon is richer 50 times more than
all these people and even more famous
and i just feel like it's always a pile
on when it comes to influencers because
there is this like negative stigma about
influencers and
yes is this completely ethical i don't
think so but i just hate to like jump on
the bandwagon
like honestly like i think we should
ride it outside reese witherspoon's
house you know what i mean like
to me that's more egregious and now it
feels like there's more backlash about
this
just because it's like so easy to make
fun of influences yeah and especially
bachelor people and i think you made a
good point before when you said that
like
an influencer's job is like to show a
house it kind of put on a front yeah and
so but then that also makes it really
easy to think that you know everything
about them and you can look like
look at their checkbook and be like you
don't deserve this loan yeah but but
then
that's also the blessing and the curse
of like putting so much of yourself out
there like why do i know that lauren and
already have a second home in hawaii
because they made a youtube video about
it so if you're going to be that
transparent things like this are going
to happen so i also think that if if we
looked at the list of people who got
loans
the whole list from top to bottom most
money given
people who received it i think there's
probably way bigger fish to fry
for sure than than some of these
bachelors in their 20k it was like 900
billion dollars given out and like
they're 20
100 they're definitely shadiness and it
just sucks that like
there were definitely so many businesses
who didn't get approved
um but also i think what maybe people
don't know is like if you're
like a tasha or like an influencer and
you have an llc
you are not eligible to collect
unemployment like so like millions of
americans did over the last year and
that's how they were
sustaining when they got laid off and so
you're not eligible for that so this is
like an alternate route
to sustain your business again is it 100
ethical
and morally correct i don't think so
but i just think there's more to it you
know
yeah and i think that we we shouldn't
lump everyone in because i give a major
pass
to brian absolo and to colton and like
colton's in the headlines and honestly
he's and trust me it's killing me to say
something nice about colton like it
really is but
what's right is right and what's wrong
is wrong to me like the dale
the taisha and the aryan lauren it's
like it doesn't look good
but again i don't know how much money
you have so it just feels weird to like
count people's money
but that's i guess what we're doing yeah
exactly
well we'll keep you posted if anyone
else makes a statement so far just
tasha and colton and i also think that
um you know given that this has become a
bit of a mess i
i do think that everyone should just
sort of share what they used it for yeah
if they want to clear things up
well so this is where it gets shady when
you get the loan on these websites
it you have to break down how much of
the money you're going to use towards
um paychecks rent utilities resources or
whatever
and if you are an llc like you know dale
is and he's his only employee because
it's his company
that paychecks only goes to you so it
feels very weird
yeah and if it says you know you know
dale moss llc
one employee and then the twenty all the
money they went to payroll it went to
the one employee who was dale moss and
the
the thing about ppp loans i watched
jason tardik's igtv
it's very informative so if you give all
or most of
your ppp loan to pay salaries whether
that's your one employee aka yourself or
your dozens of employees like i'm sure
bryan
colton your loan if it goes mostly to
paychecks
is completely most of the time if a
forgivable loan like you don't have to
pay it back that's why it's not really a
loan it's just like free money
which is why so many people jumped on
free money i don't have to give the
money back to the government of course
like
so that's why it feels even weirder
because they had to give the money to
themselves in order to
not have to pay back yeah thank you for
that thank you for the expert in the ppp
space
by by way of jason tardik
well you did a good job summing it up
thank you are you ready for our next
story
sure jamie lynn spears breaks her
silence on britney spears testimony and
i totally forgot about those in a series
of instagram stories jamie lynn was
emotional at times as she explained how
proud she is of brittany for using her
voice
noting that she finally defeated decided
to speak out after the pop
princess did she said the only reason i
haven't spoken before is because i felt
like until my sister was able to speak
for herself and say what she felt she
needed to say publicly
that it wasn't my place and it wasn't
the right thing to do but now that she's
very clearly spoken and said what she
needed to say i feel like i can follow
her lead and say what i feel like i need
to say
she basically just said she supports her
whatever she wants to do yes and what
she needed to say
it wasn't that much she said quote i
don't care if she wants to run away to a
rainforest and have a zillion babies in
the middle of nowhere or if she wants to
come back and dominate the world
the way she has done so many times
before because i have nothing to gain or
lose either way
the situation does not affect me either
way because i'm only her sister who is
only concerned about her happiness
so let me say when i watch the stories i
did feel like they were genuine
and i did kind of appreciate her just
let me finish before you guys get angry
okay okay
i did kind of appreciate i thought it
was genuine even though like when she
said all she really you know cares about
her like only interest is being an aunt
to those boys and then she wiped away
fake tear like i did
notice that there was no tear to wipe um
but for the most part i thought it was
genuine and i agree like
public support versus private support
like you don't again like you don't know
what goes on between families and like
i think that she gets lumped into her
dad jamie it doesn't help that they have
the same name
also her husband's name is jamie like
there's a lot but i did appreciate
her kind of i'm my own person like my
dad is my dad i am me i support brittany
and i left the video feeling like okay
good like brittany has someone in our
corner
and then i read people's responses and i
just found myself like agreeing with
them
hardcore the comments on the toast
instagram were not here
for what she gave and they had good
reasoning like first of all comparing
you know flying to mars and moving to
the amazon to have babies with just
wanting her freedom it was just like
kind of condescending like i don't care
what she does you want to end the
conservative ship or fly to mars like
they're not the same thing like one is a
basic human right and one is like insane
and you're also like kind of making it
seem like she's asking for something so
crazy yeah yeah i just
somebody pointed that out i'm like you
know what that is kind of rude yeah then
what else someone pointed out she made
it clear and i think what she was trying
to say was like a lot of people think
she wants to keep
britney in the conservatorship because
you know she gets financial benefits
from it but she's like no i've been
paying my own bills i get nothing out of
this since she was 10.
since she was 10. but that's not
entirely factually correct because
according to the legal paperwork in 2018
she was put on as a trustee of
the the boys
the sons brittany's sons like uh
inheritance or whatever like that's what
she was put on so then you're like okay
maybe she's just like a protective
auntie which you know you and i can
totally understand
we can relate but like who she enlisted
as like the executor was like this shady
like i watched this
like she hasn't acted in the benefit of
brittany for the last couple years
legally so there was just like a lot of
conflicting arguments coming from
her because at first at face value i
watched i'm like oh this is nice we love
sisters who support sisters and you know
what goes on in the public eye like we
really don't know and you know private
relationships are private
and then like there was just
inconsistencies being pointed out like
in different tick tocks and i'm like oh
that's a fair that's a fair point yeah i
felt the way about
i felt that way about the instagram
comments on the toast yeah
of the video where it was just like nope
this isn't they're not accepting it
and the fake tear should have been my
first indicator that
this wasn't 100 genuine yeah and then
also i think people were kind of um put
off by her tone
very defensive very defensive so
i think i don't i don't know if it had
the intended effect
she had to turn off her instagram
comments i'm sure she's been getting so
much hate this is like the biggest story
in the world and people
and brittany really in her statement
explicitly said my family my family i'm
mad at my family i want to sue my family
my family doesn't let me do this
not my dad or my parents she said her
family so jamie
lynn and jamie is your family yeah so
color us confusion so it's still not
clear and i feel like up until this
statement came out i really wasn't
thinking about jamie lynn's involvement
too much me neither and now i am because
i was like you know what sisters or
sisters
like it's private but there's and i'm
sure
even though we just got like a boatload
of information over the last week
i'm sure there is still so much that we
don't know 100
so it's hard like i really try not to
judge but now there's
like now they put more out there yeah
and i think it also has to do with the
fact that like in the last couple years
jamie lynn has had like a resurgence to
the spotlight she's on that show sweet
magnolia is on netflix
she did that zoe 101 reboot song with
like chantal jeffries so she has a lot
to lose now she does have like a
like a platform and a career and she's
kind of become
villainized in this story so i think
this was her attempt to like you know
shut the haters down and i think the
haters have been blown wide open
yeah the haters just got more fuel yeah
well are you ready for our next story i
don't know before we do i'm feeling
oddly reminiscent i'd love to take a
trip down memory lane maybe watch some
old home dvds brought to you by legacy
box i would love that claudia
give the gift of memories this year for
an anniversary you and your spouse will
never forget
isn't ensuring that your family's legacy
is digitally preserved so it can be pa
be passed down just as important as
creating those memories
welcome legacy box a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your past
the process from start to finish is so
easy
you pack and send all your old you know
vhs's anything you haven't been able to
access or watch but home videos
basically legacy box will digitize
everything by hand and then you enjoy
you get back perfectly preserved
digital copies on a thumb drive a dvd or
the cloud and it's ready to watch and
share and enjoy
they've thought of everything in the
process they provide state-of-the-art
tracking and they send you updates at
every step of the process
you send your previous recorded moments
to a company that you can trust legacy
box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
they've helped more than a million
families preserve their past
this is such a good gift for really
anyone like a sister
a parent a grandparent because
technology is constantly evolving and
like we have so many home videos
that for so long we were never able to
watch you like sat in our storage unit
and like re-watching them is literally
like entering a new world and it's so
fun and it's just like a great gift for
someone and then you spend the whole day
watching it is such a good activity and
it really is the gift that keeps on
giving
and right now legacy box is offering 40
off so your family can celebrate
meaningful moments at a fraction of the
normal price
i get dms all the time like what was the
legacy box listen up
legacybox.com toast to get started
that's legacybox.com toast for the 40
off legacybox.com post
thank you for that and i love when we
talk about legacy box right before we
talk about a kardashian because
legacy box just reminds me of the
kardashians and the theme song of
the kardashians with all those old home
movies is literally like an ad for a
legacy box 100
and speaking of team usa will be wearing
kim kardashian's skins at the olympics
i'm so proud of our girl like i really
am such amazing news for some kardashian
stands and olympic correspondents it
really doesn't get any better than this
this is a convergence of like literally
everything we've been talking about over
the last month
over our lives well yeah kim kardashian
announced on monday that her skims brand
will serve as team usa's official
provider of undergarments and pajamas
for the 2021 tokyo olympics as well as
for the paralympics
she said when i received the call
inviting skims to be part of team usa
every moment i've spent admiring the
strength and energy of the olympians
from the
sidelines came full circle she tweeted
do you remember when kim launched skims
after doing like a bunch of projects
that didn't feel like super authentic to
her like emoji she was making all this
merch
and we just felt like she was trying to
find her niche kind of how kylie found
kylie cosmetics
we said it then and we said it now like
skims is very much on its way to being a
billion dollar company if they're not
even already there
and this is so this legitimizes her
brand
so much this takes it from being like a
direct to consumer influencer brand
to like literally being like a haines
like who normally does this like
fruit of the loom well this is the first
time oh no
i'm well this is marked the first time a
brand's been named as the team's
official underwear so they've never had
official underwear and pjs before
ralph lauren does the uniforms so it's
kim and ralph
like no because you know what and i was
thinking i'm like what honestly what is
more american than the olympics and the
kardashians like
it's so american and honestly ralph
lauren making the
um uniform uniforms and every season i
know they do like ralph lauren like usa
stuff it's like preppy
it's very american it's not me but it's
very american like i love that kim is
like the next ralph lauren
it's so amazing and then also when she
was talking she was tweeting and
instagramming about you know how much
this means to her she talks about
caitlyn and how much like the olympics
was part of their lives growing up
because of caitlyn
and so it really is just such a full
circle moment she posted some pictures
of some of the athletes like in
the skims branded pjs underwear socks
everything loungewear
and it's just such cute stuff and as an
owner of skins like
it is so comfortable so these athletes
are gonna be sleeping like babies
oh wait and it's also going to become
available to the public so like say your
alarms if i don't get something like i
will cry
set your alarms i'm so happy for like
this legitimizes the brand
so much and it's just like a great
convergence of different
of things of like of you know athletes
and
global sports and fashion like it's just
it's so stunning and i think this like
whosever idea this was is a [ __ ]
genius
i i want to know like how it went down
who called who who called yeah exactly
because um she said team usa reached out
so like
someone there is just like a person of
taste
someone there is literally the
definition of in tune with what's
necessary yeah the designs include
bralettes boxer briefs tank tops briefs
t-shirts socks leggings and more
honestly i forget all the time that
caitlyn was an olympian just because
she's done so much with her life
since then that i forget that at one
point she won
what was it the like triathlon yeah like
all of them you've been watching track
and field yeah i haven't seen that one
yeah it's like it's like you do all of
them yeah the decathlon the decathlon
yes it is
yeah very very yeah not triathlon cause
that's like biking swimming like iron
man
yeah um but you know what i guess i'm
going to move my stories around because
that's a great segue too
story oh wait before i do i just wanted
to share one
other olympics related story because
hearts back to something we were talking
about yesterday about
family members not being able to go to
the olympics which is just really
bothering me the more you think about it
and now a canadian basketball player who
um just gave birth and is like
breastfeeding can't bring her baby
you're kidding me with her to tokyo so
she has to choose between her daughter
and the olympics and she's trying no but
like
no come on the kid will be there when
you get back put him on formula but
she's still breastfeeding
oh my god that sucks that's not right
that's hard she's trying to petition to
like get
exception me but like that's mommy this
is ridiculous that's mom phobic
it's imagine qualifying for the olympics
right after giving birth like
this woman must be an elite athlete it's
just so crazy the more i hear about this
policy
the stupider it is and they can't make
well you know canada does have like a
lot of problems with covid like
honestly i if that happened in the
states so many people are vaccinated i
do feel like
that person would be able to get like an
exception like because it's so
extraordinary like of course you could
bring your baby
it's it's the ioc rules it's not
canada's rules
but i'm sure they're not really you know
dying to let one more person from canada
come canada's like raging with coven
right
no baby i know but like i think it was
if it was from someone from america
where like we're kind of like not to
like
brag like we're like killing it like
with the we are like looking
at the vaccination we lifted the mask
mandate like we are so ahead of the
curve when we were so behind the curve
for so long
and like we're i don't know we're just
like sickening you know and canada is
like deeply problematic like people are
still in their houses i know we have so
many toasters in canada who like
literally
rely on the show as a lifeline to hear
what's going on in the world because
they can't leave their houses
yeah so i think like the fact that she's
canadian like it's not helping her cause
but i agree it's still unethical like
to make to make a woman choose like it's
disgraceful it's disgraceful there
should be an exception made and also
like they should just allow family
members who've worked their whole lives
to watch their
family go to the olympics go to the
olympics and also
um can't babies like not
carry cover they can get it but they
can't give it they can't transmit it it
make it make sense please i mean i
really hope that um i hope she she gets
to go on that she doesn't have to choose
but like that's crazy that she even what
would you train now
i'd choose the olympics i would keep
fighting i would bring yeah of course
but like if it came down to it and you
didn't win
like so you either had to just like
knock oh or
leave your breastfeeding child to you
know with the with
the partner maybe a nanny and like some
formula the kid will be fine
the kid would be fine the kid would be
fine but like you don't want to miss
those
moments of course no it's so wrong and
unethical but like you know
that's just push comes to shove i'm
getting on the plane
that's just not right okay all right now
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more sports news
unless it's the france i'm not
interested it is the tour de france news
because the spectator who caused a
massive crash at tour de france
is now missing after fleeing the country
wouldn't you
oh my god the shame this woman is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
a spectator at the tour de france who
caused a massive crash involving dozens
of cyclists
is missing as race authorities planned
to sue her tour department's deputy
director pierre yves tulan
told ace eve saint laurent told
apf news agency they plan to sue the
woman so that the tiny minority of
people who do this don't spoil the show
for every
everyone however the uh french
publication
uh believes that the woman got on a
flight is and is untraceable she's
believed
to be german the video shows the woman
who held a long banner on the sidelines
of the race
stick the banner out a little too far a
little like she was like
bulging so hard into the path and i i
don't know if she didn't see the people
behind her she was like a prankster who
tried to
you know ruin the tour de france but
the people the leaders of the biking
segment were literally like right behind
her
and one person accidentally knocked into
her lost his balance
and literally knocked over 50 other
people it was a domino effect
it was literally like a mosh pit of
cyclists
and it's so sad for so many reasons one
so many people got hurt i saw a guy
literally he
fell and somebody rode over him with his
bike like it was a stampede
so first of all so many people got hurt
second of all these are athletes who
have trained their whole life and they
were in the front they were in the lead
like they actually had a chance of
winning
and this woman just absolutely ruined it
the sign was a hello message
to her grandparents i can't the [ __ ]
she's gonna ruin it for everyone because
soon there won't be able to be
spectators well but then that was my
other question
i thought it was interesting that there
was like not even so much as like a
barricade like when you have a parade
here in new york you want to watch from
the sidelines you can't just watch
unobstructed there's a barricade in
front of you
and i do feel like there's a little bit
of blame to be put
on the tour de france administrators
like why are you just letting random
people
stand four inches from the biker like
this close someone could throw a rock or
a
like a stick like it's kind of stupid i
agree i'm sure and hopefully they'll put
more measures into place but maybe they
think just by suing her that they'll
discourage other people from doing it
no i think maybe like a red velvet rope
like
something could help yeah no a barricade
yeah
so when i saw that i was like damn i
don't know people could literally stand
on the road that the cyclists are
cycling on that's
kind of like asking for trouble yeah i
agree because everybody just like wants
their five seconds of fame yeah of
course and like
if you are this woman like what's going
through your mind you're there's a
nationwide manhunt you escaped
so when it happened the woman
darted obviously but then she was caught
on camera one more time she's wearing a
bright yellow coat like it's so easy to
find her
she's like she's a few feet down um like
trying to watch what happens and then
she disappeared so she was spotted twice
and can you imagine like she has to have
facial reconstruction surgery or at
least like she's short
she's like a brown pixie cut like girl
get a wig like you are the most wanted
woman in europe right now
yeah or she should hold herself
accountable turn yourself in
turn yourself in yeah so did anyone win
the tour de france we have to start over
i don't know this um i think this news
sort of eclipsed
anything yeah of course like nobody
actually cares yeah and i saw like but
the bikers getting up they had like
blood coming out of their arms and like
and they wanted to finish because it's a
it's something you work for your whole
life
it is so dangerous you know what this
reminded me of
even though it's not even in any way the
same but like the girl looked the same
remember when that girl
crashed the chanel fashion show and gg
had like literally shoved her off the
stage
yeah she just gave me the same energy as
that girl even though that girl was like
fully a prankster and i do believe this
was like an accident
i didn't get the same energy because i
got like really loser energy from this
like
do you think this was an accident yeah
i i i do think it was an accident but
stupid is stupid yeah no like accident
from accident like
you're wrong no like it's really not
that hard to see that your sign your big
dumb sign was like
about to touch a and wasn't paying
attention nobody cares about
you and your grandparents being on tv
like literally nobody cares like
no no and like so she tried you're
telling me she traveled from germany
to france just to hold out a sign made
of actual like used cardboard and
sharpie to say hi to our grandparents
like why don't you go visit them
i i can't understand or relate to her
behavior whatsoever
i would just like love i you know what i
need honestly like i need a movie about
like
the the week after from this girl's pov
like the week after like what do you do
when when this happens because you make
a big mistake it causes it like a
global scandal and then you have to flee
and like you you have to do
you definitely have to change your
appearance like people it's all over the
news it's everywhere and it's a blurry
photo but like it's so pretty
pretty easy to tell like what she looks
like so i would love like a jackie style
movie where we get like the 48 hours
after jfk dies
but like the week after the tour de
france and i would prefer that movie
from like the person who crashed into
her signs point of view the person who
actually worked towards something yeah i
know
he's trying to accomplish something and
maybe like he could be a part of like
then the story of trying to find her but
i really don't need
to understand this woman's pov
whatsoever i don't need to understand it
i'm just dying to know what's going
through her mind right now like she must
be
freaking the [ __ ] out she should be you
think she went straight from the tour to
the airport
like that's what i'm saying i need you
to logistically like what did she do
next
i don't know she burned that coat is
what she did hopefully
hopefully okay ready for our fifth and
final story
is it the final story
it's the final story brought to you by
hush blankets let's talk about the
quality of your sleep the reality is
over 160 million americans struggle with
sleep and hush is here to help
they have a wide range of sleep
essentials for every sleeper whether
you're a hot sleeper or cold sleeper
hush has what you need to get the job
done they carry everything from pillows
and sheets to their best-selling
weighted blankets which we can attest to
are everything of the sort
very durable i've had mine for over a
year they even have an iced weighted
blanket that keeps you cool all night
because if you get warm when you sleep
or sweaty when you sleep you might think
like a weighted blanket's not for me
but they have one made just for you if
you're looking to improve your nightly
rest
hush is the answer if you're not 100
sold hush has a hundred night guarantee
on all of their products you try it out
for a hundred nights and return it with
no hassle whatsoever
we both have the hush throw blanket i
have it like in a navy blue it's very
pretty i've seen a lot of
weird blankets that are truly heinous
and look like they belong in a hospital
but this one's like a stunning throw but
it just happens to like weigh
i think around eight pounds um and it's
everything in the store yeah
something that's super important to us
is giving back which is why we love hush
even more from day one they have donated
one in ten adult blankets and one in
five kids blankets to those in need
around the world
so if you're looking to upgrade your
sleep head over to hushblankets.com
and use the code toast for 40 off your
next purchase it's valid on all the
products
so that's the pillows the sheets the
weighted blankets
at hushblankets.com code toast for forty
dollars off
it is the biggest discount they offer so
make sure to check it out
hushblankets.com code toast for forty
dollars off
thank you for that fifth and final story
um southern charms madison lacroix is
embarrassed after exposing herself
during a drunk instagram live well she
should be
yeah this is kind of weird on monday the
southern charm star spoke out about her
wild sunday night in a series of
instagram stories
explaining that last night was not my
best fans who were following the cry on
instagram know what she was referring to
throughout the evening lacroix and a
female friend went live on instagram
upwards of 16 times
all while partying at home on their
friend who used to date austin
yes so claudia was explaining she caught
some of the lives
and it was so like it's
like i love her like i do i really love
her but she's making it really really
hard like yeah
first of all this whole like there was
like all that drama back in covid where
like you know austin would go live and
then madison would go live and like it
was fresh off the break up and it was
kind of like fun and juicy but like and
people were going live
yeah but like this is now just sad
because it's like a whole year later
and they broke up on the show so that
was like two years ago and on the show
she was like
she was one who broke up with him she
wanted a clean break she wanted to see
other people
and now it's just like kind of like
losery and desperate to like be hanging
out with some random girl that austin
like
like used to date and like trying to get
back at him when he's like literally
living his best life doing winter house
hanging out with kristen cavallari like
he's just literally like on another
level and we thought that was going to
be madison because madison was when we
broke up with him so it's just like this
is not how i saw the story ending
and it's not looking good for madison
and she is not helping her on cause no
not at all on the lives they were
dancing climbing on furniture saying
along to song said party in the usa and
we're never getting back together
that is so lame at one point she
accidentally flashed the camera exposing
her bare chest
and then she proceeded to flash the
camera multiple times after that
looking back on it monday she told her
followers she wasn't exactly thrilled
with her behavior she said yes i feel
awful
embarrassed drunk still i had a good
time like clearly
so you and i always say like people who
go live on instagram
drunk nope no no no it's such a big no
no i think i used to do that like when i
was in college like before i really
understood like my platform and like it
was the dumbest thing ever
like i can't believe that there are
people who still do that like especially
grown adults like
it's the dumbest thing you could do yeah
like i will never
i agree just like have a good time with
your friend hanging out get drunk like
growing live 16 times is a little oh and
the 16 times
and now it's like over covered like
because i follow about us and i would
get like notifications like madison the
car is going live and i'll be like nah
and now i'm like oh my god again like
it's the non-stop notifications and i
just feel like her lives have gotten her
into trouble so many times
and she keeps going live yeah and the
like she has to stop like 100 yeah
end it now and it now i don't think it's
the end
i really don't definitely not and like
are we filming
we're always filming you know well not
us they
i feel like they are probably filming i
hope so because there's been a lot of
stuff going on with sewing down south
and i feel like craig would wait for all
that until they're filming there's also
just been like a lot of
stuff going on in the southern charm
world like i feel like southern charm
hit like a little bit of a lull
in the past couple seasons but they're
coming back like very strong like
there's a lot going on
chris the christian cavalier of it all
which i don't understand also austin and
craig just being like these guys about
town being on winter house like there's
just like a lot
yeah and katherine is like literally a
different human being like i don't know
like she looks she looks great but so
different yeah so there's just like a
lot to discuss
there is i'm always excited for southern
charm to come back me too
um and i do believe that's our show yeah
i haven't had that fact checked yet but
it's
our show it looks as though it is our
show and it is coming to an end as that
is all she wrote
i didn't consume any other content
yesterday other than the book and
tonight where honey
is on and tonight i'm sitting down for a
podcast for the patreon
with olivia ashrae renowned mom i'm so
excited that you just shared that
because i forgot to tell everyone that
if i look a little different this
morning
you do like what's what's different so i
did get ready with me i did my hair and
makeup tutorial my everyday hair and
makeup and i filmed all of it so that
vlog will be
up today i actually wound up like i
looked so much better on the vlog
and then like a lot of time passed and
then i came here
and not looking like super glam but like
trust like the hair was done and
everything and then i just like put in a
pony because i wound up wearing like
such a sporty outfit i can't help but be
such a sporty girl
but that will be up today patreon.com
morning toast it's
actually never too late to become a
patreon member our subscription service
it costs you 7.99
a month you get five extra episodes from
us their podcast their vlogs they're
pretty much anything you want you can
request
any type of content once you become a
member you get to join the facebook
group where you can put in any requests
get questions for olivia so many
questions about motherhood career
balancing and all
her birth story even though we have done
her birth story on an episode i think
like a few months ago maybe she'll
improvise
yeah and also if you join the patreon
you get access to every episode we've
ever done on patreon which is now well
over 200 so
for 7.99 it ain't a bad price it's a
bargain
and yeah my tutorial everything i do
every day this is my everyday makeup and
hair how i use my dyson air app like oh
that you know i would love to watch that
like yeah i think it's
i mean that's that's what i do you know
so if you're ever curious
what i use for my eyebrows blah blah
blah yeah it's all there what do you use
for eyebrows nothing
no i use benefit gimme brows two are you
shade five
dark yeah i know i'm just like so cara
delevingne
totally well that's our show thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast
the wait the millennial morning show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
wait yeah no i'm having like a stroke
it's okay
thank you so much for listening to the
morning tells the money morning show
where we deliver the festive stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes central public video i
have ready to guest box all the places
where we listen to the podcast if i just
want to just leave you five star viewers
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day we'll see
you tomorrow for
hump day goodbye
you